We are at a turning point in transportation.
Although gas cars still dominate the roads,
it's becoming increasingly clear that the
future of transport is electric and a lot of
this excitement is because of one company. Tesla
is disrupting the automotive industry by creating
affordable EVs of all kinds. But it almost didn't
make it. Success was a longshot and Elon Musk knew
it. When we first started Tesla and SolarCity we
thought they would fail. Tesla, in particular,
we thought probably we've maybe 10% chance of
success. This is not the story of a company
that nearly died many times. This is the story of
a man who would not give up. This is the story of
Elon Musk's perseverance against all odds. In
2003, in Silicon Valley, two engineers created
Tesla. Martin Eberhard and Marc Tarpenning. They
named it after Serbian-American inventor Nikola
Tesla. Back then, Tesla was called Tesla Motors.
They saw an opportunity to create an electric
car after General Motors recalled the EV1 - the
first mass-produced electric car in the modern
era. It's unclear why GM did this - it could have
been because of a lack of demand, high production
costs, or pressure from the oil and gas industry.
Either way, GM crushed the cars in a junkyard.
Elon came into the picture when the founders went
looking for funding. He made millions when the
financial services company he co-founded, x.com,
merged with a rival and became PayPal. When eBay
bought PayPal in 2002, Elon walked away with $180
million. He was very successful. But instead of
calling it a career, he sunk all his winnings into
new ventures. He put $100 million into SpaceX,
$10 million into SolarCity, and $70 million
into Tesla including $6.5 million at the start,
and became the chairman of the company's board.
So, all of the money just came from me personally.
I didn't want to ask people - other investors
- for money if I thought we were going to die.
2006 was a big year for Tesla. The roadster
made its official appearance: a good-looking,
fast electric car. But there were quality issues
and a lot of production problems. In the end,
Eberhard was ousted as CEO before the Roadster
even went into production which didn't happen
until 2008. Tesla was running out of money. The
company budgeted $25 million for the development
of the Roadster but it ended up costing nearly
five times that. By the fall of 2008, Tesla had
only $9 million left to fund the entire company.
It was a tumultuous time with multiple CEOs
coming and going and in the end, Elon was left in
charge. He said this in an interview about the big
decision he had to make: "...do I let Tesla die or
do I make it live with a lot of pain and grief?"
He chose to make Tesla live but it couldn't have
been more painful. One of America's largest banks,
Lehman Brothers, collapsed, sinking the world
economy into the worst recession since the
Great Depression. Plus, SpaceX was close to being
bankrupt after three failed rocket launches. And,
he was going through a divorce from his wife
Justine. Elon said 2008 was the worst year of
his life and he never thought he was someone
capable of having a nervous breakdown but came
close to it. Elon fought hard to save his
companies. He cut 25% of Tesla's workforce
and asked friends to help cover payroll. But by
December 2008, Tesla was about to die. Still,
he didn't give up. He scraped together $20 million
from various sources, including the money he made
investing in his cousin's data center startup
Everdream which Dell had bought the year before.
Investors agreed to match what he cobbled up and
in the end, Elon managed to secure a $40 million
round of financing on Christmas Eve. It was the
last hour of the last day that it was possible.
Ashlee Vance wrote a biography about Elon Musk
and there's one dinner conversation that Elon
had with a Tesla investor that really shows
his tenacity. During that dinner, Elon said,
I will spend my last dollar on these companies. If
we have to move into Justine's parents' basement,
we'll do it. Tesla barely pulled through in 2008
but needed more money to stay alive. That came in
May 2009 when German automaker Daimler invested
$15 million by taking a 10% stake in the company.
Daimler and Tesla had already been working on an
electric smart car. The company also received a
$465 million loan from the U.S. Department of
Energy which had a program backing clean tech
startups. The following year, Tesla found a more
stable solution when it went public at $17 a
share. Despite the problems with the Roadster,
Tesla had achieved something no company had
ever done before.It proved that electric cars
could be cool and fast. But the Roadster was too
expensive for most people - costing more than
$100,000. So, they built another car. In 2012,
Tesla stunned the world when it began shipping
the Model S sedan. It took everyone's breath
away. The Model S could go more than 300 miles on
a single charge and it was more affordable than
the Roadster although still expensive. Tesla's
problems were still not over and nearly went
bankrupt again in 2013. Even though the Model
S was in high demand, customers who put down a
$5,000 deposit were hesitant about going through
with their purchase. There were a lot of reasons
for this: complaints about the interior, kinks
with the car, some of the earliest versions
didn't have parking sensors and cruise control
which are common in high-end vehicles. There were
also concerns about the resale value. We were
operating with maybe one to two weeks of money.
When Elon found out about the problem he did
three things. First, he turned every Tesla
employee into a salesperson. They called
everyone who put down a deposit and tried
to convince them to go through with buying the
car. Second, he convinced his friend Larry Page,
the CEO of Google, to buy Tesla if the company
actually did run out of money. Finally, Tesla
shut down its factory when orders weren't coming
in fast enough but did not admit this publicly,
or else it would have scared investors and
sent the stock price plummeting. Instead,
Tesla said it was closing down for maintenance
which was technically true but not the whole
story. The strategy worked. On May 8, 2013, Tesla
stunned Wall Street by posting its first-ever
profit as a public company. Tesla made $11 million
on $562 million in sales after delivering 4,900
Model S's in the first quarter. Elon saved Tesla
from death again. But there were more hardships to
come. The company's problems were still not over
and nearly went bankrupt again in 2018. This time,
it had to do with the Model 3. Elon's vision from
the beginning was to build an affordable electric
car paid for by the more expensive cars - the
Model S and also the Model X which came out a
few years earlier. The Model 3 had a base price of
$35,000. This is kind of crazy but I just learnt,
I was just told that the total number
of orders for the Model 3 in the past
24 hours has now passed 115,000. But the
huge demand also meant the company had to
produce the cars in time. And frankly, we're
gonna be in production hell. Welcome, welcome.
As the saying goes, if you're
going through hell, keep going.
Tesla struggled to meet its production targets. It
initially wanted to produce 5,000 Model 3s a week
but in the first three months of 2018, it made
just 9,800 of them. Tesla was bleeding money as it
tried to increase production of the car. It lost
$1 billion dollars in the first half of 2019 and
scrambled to raise capital. Elon said the company
was close to death within single-digit weeks. He
even slept on the factory floor because he didn't
have time to go home and also because he says he
wanted to suffer more than any other employee.
Despite the torturous production process,
Tesla managed to pull through once again. It
turned a corner in the second half of 2019 by
delivering over 92,000 Model 3s in the fourth
quarter - that's an increase from the same
period the year before or a year-over-year of
46%. And the latest model - the Model Y - was
ahead of schedule. Tesla has managed to survive.
Now it's looking ahead to many ambitious plans,
including fully autonomous driving, a million-mile
battery, and driverless cabs called robotaxis.
Tesla's stock price hovers around $1,000 a share
as of the making of this video but the biggest
bulls see it going up way more. Tesla has endured
many near-death experiences and through it all,
Elon has never ever given up. It's
hard to stay alive as a car company,
honestly. Not only is Tesla alive but because
of his vision, ambition, and relentless drive,
its future is still being written. Thanks somuch
for watching, I'm Cindy Pom. If you liked what
you saw, give us a like, and don't forget to
subscribe to my new channel. While you're at it,
hit that notification bell so you'll
know when I upload a new video. I hope
to do a lot more stories on topics that
I find super interesting. See you soon.